Good morning.
Today we move in the direction
that takes a big turn from the
direction we have been going in
so far.
All the devices we have had up
until now, resistors and voltage
sources, and even your digital
devices like the AND gate or the
inverter and so on had a very
specific property.
We didn't dwell on that
property, but that property was
that these were not what are
called memory devices.
In other words,
the outputs at any given time
are a function of the inputs
alone.
In other words,
if you took your inverter or
your NAND gate for that matter
and you build a circuit
comprising 50 NAND gates
connected in structures that we
have talked about,
you apply an input and boom you
get an output.
And your output is a function
of the inputs alone,
right?
The same thing with your
resistors and voltage sources.
At any given point in time your
output VO of T was some function
of the input VI of T.
What we are going to do today
is discuss a new element which
will introduce a whole new class
of fun stuff for all of us to
deal with.
And that is called storage.
In other words,
the output of a circuit is now
going to depend not just on the
inputs but it is going to depend
on the background or it is going
to depend on where the circuit
has been in the past.
So past is going to matter.
It is a very fundamental
difference.
And what I would like to do is
start by giving you folks a
little bit of a surprise.
I am going to do a little demo
taking two of your inverter
circuits.
I am going to start by taking a
couple of inverters.
Remember, I am using this
structure here as an inverter.
And I am going to couple this
to another inverter and take an
output C, some VS,
some load resistance RL,
my B terminal and my A
terminal.
So I'm going to apply some
input between ground and my A
terminal.
And for fun I want to apply a
square wave at the input.
A square wave between zero and
5 volts.
And this is how my time goes.
Let's assume that VS is 5
volts.
So what I am going to do is
plot for you the behavior of
this inverter.
I am going to plot for you A,
which would look like this.
I am going to plot for you B,
which would be the inverted
wave form.
And then plot C,
which would be a wave form that
looks like this again.
Let me do a plot here.
So this is A.
-- and so on.
Time goes this way.
And let's say this is between
zero and 5 volts.
And B should be an inverted
wave form that should look like
this.
If all that we believe of the
world so far is true then this
is how things should behave,
so C should look like this.
This is what the world should
look like and if everything that
you learned about is true and
correct and all of the good
stuff.
Let me show you a little demo
and see if I can try to pull the
rug out from under all that you
have learned so far and show you
some surprising stuff.
Here are the three wave forms
that I showed you up here.
This is my A.
This is my A wave form.
This is the B wave form.
Notice that B,
as you expect,
is an inverted form of A.
And this is C.
We all expect this,
correct?
But what I am going to do is
let me expand the time scale on
this so that I can look at these
transitions a little bit more
carefully.
I am just going to expand the
time scale.
There you go.
All I have done is expanded the
time scale and spread that out a
little bit.
And what you see there is quite
different from what you expect.
A is a square wave as expected,
but B is stunningly different.
It is a zero as expected
because this is a one.
But here I get some really
strange behavior,
behavior that is like nothing
on earth.
Like nothing you have seen
before.
And then, of course,
it becomes a one eventually,
but there's some really,
really shady stuff going on
here.
And so far you are not prepared
to deal with this.
We have not given you the
facility to deal with his issue.
What is the problem with this?
We could say who cares?
Let's look at the result.
I am looking at this,
I am focusing on this piece
here.
And notice that instead of
being a sharp rise it looks like
this.
It is going up a little bit
more slowly.
What kind of problem would that
create?
The problem that it creates is
the following.
Let me play around with this
graph a little bit more.
What I am going to do is just
take this output here,
the C output and line it up
against the A output.
And so I am going to line up
the C wave form on top of the A
wave form.
So you can see for yourself if
something really,
really strange and nasty is
happening, I am just going to
move up the C wave form and line
it up.
What is happening out there?
If you look carefully,
what you observe is that the C
wave form transitions just ever
so slightly later than the A
wave form.
Look here.
And I claim that it is because
of this.
Because of this,
the C wave form falls just a
little bit later,
and that little thing we see
out there is a delay.
So nothing you have learned so
far prepares you for this.
Suddenly, instead of the output
exactly following the input,
my output is following the
input but a little bit later.
And it is this fact of life
that things happen a little bit
later, is really the reason why
each of you and all of us needs
to buy new computers every
couple of years.
This simple basic fact.
If this fact of life didn't
exist, you would buy one
computer and be done with it for
life.
Intel would make gobs of money
one year, and so would Dell and
Gateway and so on,
and then no more.
That's it.
This is it.
But because of this a little
itty-bitty difference here the
entire semiconductor technology
is charging along trying to do
something about that.
You buy newer and newer
computers each year.
It turns out this little
itty-bitty thing here,
that is called the delay,
the inverter delay.
And it happens because of a
specific element that has been
introduced here that we have not
shown you so far.
And a large part of the
semiconductor industry and
follow-on courses and design and
so on focuses on how could I
make my delay smaller,
how can I get to be faster and
faster and faster?
This relates to how fast we can
clock your Pentium IV.
Remember it came all the way to
1.3 gigahertz?
What's the fasted Pentium money
can buy today?
What is the fastest P4?
Oh, 3.2 have come out?
I don't know.
Ken claims 3.2.
But, yeah, there you go,
3.2 gigahertz.
It all has to do with this
little itty-bitty thing.
You saw it for the first time
here.
When some of you become CTOs at
Intel and so on,
just remember that it all began
on October 16th with this little
rinky-dink thing here.
What you are going to learn now
is some really cool stuff that
has huge implications for life.
So why does that happen?
Why did this transition happen
just a little bit later?
The reason is that remember
when this wave form reaches VT,
the threshold voltage of this
MOSFET, this guy is going to
switch, right?
So because of the slower rise
of the voltage,
the VT is going to be reached a
small amount of time later.
So I am going to hit VT
slightly later.
And because of that this guy is
going to transition just a bit
later because this intermediate
wave form B is slower.
It hits VT just a little bit
later than if it would have made
an instantaneous transition.
And therefore my output falls
just a little bit later and this
gives rise to my delay in the
inverter.
We can call that d if you would
like, some delay.
In your course notes,
this material is covered in
Chapters 9 and 10.
That was to kind of motivate
why we are going to be doing all
that you we will be doing.
Don't anybody come within a
foot of this even by mistake.
I mean it.
It is pretty deadly stuff.
Today we will talk about the
capacitor.
And in the next couple of
lectures I am going to tie it
all together and show you how
this relates to that.
I will show you exactly how the
delay happens.
You can compute it based on
some simple principles that you
will learn about in the next
couple of lectures.
What I am going to do is first
of all show you,
I claim that that delay happens
because of the presence of a
capacitor somewhere in there.
What I will do now is take you
into a closer look,
take a closer look at the
MOSFET and show you were the
capacitor is.
This is the MOSFET that you
have seen so far,
drain, gate and source.
This is called an n-channel
MOSFET.
And what I am going to do is
dissect this and show you what
is actually happening,
what this looks like on
silicon.
So here is my slab of silicon.
It is very thin.
And let's say this is,
I won't go into details here.
You will learn a lot more about
this in future device classes
like 301 and so on,
but suffice it to say I will
just introduce it here to give
you a sense of where the
capacitor is.
This is p-type silicon.
And the way you build a MOSFET
is you create a couple of tubs
in which you dope to be n-type.
The basic silicon is dope
p-type.
And this guy here is n-type.
And what you do is a thin oxide
layer is placed on top of that
and then on top of that a thin
metal layer.
This is a metal layer.
This is a thin piece of oxide,
silicon dioxide.
And this is my P substrate.
Now this is a little metal
layer that is really a wire on
top of the silicone.
This metal layer could be some
sort of a wire that meanders
around on the surface of
silicone.
And this is a wire that
connects to the gate.
This is the gate of my MOSFET.
And this guy here is the drain.
And this guy here is the
source.
And this is my gate.
So there is a little piece of
metal here.
This is this piece of metal
here.
And there is a piece of oxide
and then my silicone substrate.
Notice that this is my oxide.
When I apply a positive voltage
to the gate here with respect to
the substrate,
what happens is that I draw up
negative charges.
I draw up electrons here into
this channel region and I have
corresponding plus type out here
so that I get a view here that
looks like a couple of plates.
And I end up with an oxide in
the middle.
There is no connection.
Two plates separated by a small
distance with plus q and minus q
on the plates.
And, because of that,
what ends up happening here is
that this piece behaves like a
capacitor.
So a capacitor has two plates
with a thin insulating material
in the middle with some
permittivity epsilon.
And so I get a little piece of
a capacitor here.
That is the capacitor that is
forming.
I did not set out to build that
capacitor, but there is a
capacitor nonetheless.
So when I apply a positive
voltage at the gate,
negative electrons are pulled
up here which forms a channel,
and then a current can then
flow.
And that is how the MOSFET
turns on.
So n-type electrons back to
n-type, and I get electron flow
here and that gives me my
channel.
This is just kind of devices in
four minutes or less.
You will do an entire course on
this, if you like,
if you take 301.
What we do is to be able to
capture the behavior that we
just saw, the funny delayed
behavior, we have to augment our
model.
We have to introduce a new
element.
So what we do is here is a
MOSFET, gate,
drain and source.
And notice here we model this
by putting a little capacitor,
CGS between our gate and the
source.
So this becomes a simple model
for our MOSFET device which is
the good old gate drain source
device from the past with a
little capacitor CGS having some
value for CGS in maybe ten to
the minus 14 or thereabouts
farads.
So that is a little capacitor
that has come about in this
device that we fabricated here.
It is that capacitor that is at
between node B and ground
because it is between the gate
and the source of the second
inverter.
And it is that capacitor that
is playing the games that we saw
out there.
So let's look at some of the
behavior of an ideal linear
capacitor.
A capacitor,
as I said, has a couple of
plates.
There are a couple of plates.
Between the plates is some
dieletric, permittivity epsilon.
Let's say the area of the
plates is A, and let's say the
plates are separated by a
distance D.
I get some charge here,
let's say q.
So q and minus q on the
capacitor.
And the capacitance C is given
by epsilon A divided by D.
Epsilon, as I said,
is the productivity of the
dielectric.
So if it is free space then it
would be epsilon zero which is
the permittivity of free space.
That is the capacitance in
farads.
And the symbol looks like this.
Capacitor C.
Voltage v.
Current i.
So this, much like the
resistor, voltage source and so
on, this now becomes a primitive
element in your tool chest of
elements like the voltage source
and so onn.
Capacitance with the voltage v
across it and a current i.
And I have assigned the
associated variables here
according to the associated
variable discipline.
A question to ask ourselves is
remember we said we are all now
in a playground from all of
nature, in this playground where
the lumped matter discipline
holds?
And also remember that we said
that for the lumped matter
discipline to hold we have to
make a couple of assumptions.
One of those assumptions was
that dq/dt, for all their
elements should be zero for all
time.
So right now what about the
capacitor?
It has got some charge q.
So charge must have built up
somehow.
Does that mean that I lied all
along, that we are no longer in
this playground,
that we have been ejected from
the playground because of the
capacitor, or are we still in
the circuits playground in which
the lumped matter discipline
holds and all good things happen
and so on?
It seems like a contradiction,
doesn't it?
I took you from Maxwell's
playgrounds to the EECS
playground where I said the
lumped matter discipline holds.
And one of the foundations of
the LMD was that dq/dt should be
zero for all time inside the
elements that we are going to
deal with.
And right now boom,
it's not four weeks into the
course and Agarwal introduces an
element and it has q in it.
It turns out that the capacitor
also adheres to the lumped
matter discipline.
Remember the discipline says
that dq/dt is zero for all time
within elements.
So I am going to be clever.
What I am going to do is I want
to choose element boundaries in
a very cleaver way.
Notice that if I have q here on
this plate then I get minus q on
the other plate.
So if I take the whole element,
the element as a whole,
if I am careful in terms of how
I package my boundaries,
if I put both my plates inside
my element boundary then I still
do get the net charge being
zero.
So dq/dt is indeed zero for all
time provided I make sure that
my element has both the plates.
Therefore, if you come across
somebody else that gives you an
element that says I have an
idea.
Let's create a new branch of
electrical engineering in which
we model the capacitor not as
one element for two plates,
but let's build a capacitor by
combining two new elements,
two garbage elements called G1
and G2.
G1 is like the top plate.
G2 is the bottom plate.
I put them together and I get a
capacitor.
But notice if I just pick one
plate then the element G1 will
not adhere to the LMD.
It adheres to the LMD because I
choose my element boundaries in
a way that both plates come
within it.
So it is very fundamental and
key.
And you can read a lot more
about it in the course notes.
I purposely dwelt on that
simple point because I think it
is foundational and important.
And you really need to
understand that the capacitor
does satisfy LMD.
We are still in the good old
playground.
A few simple facts here.
These are in the notes.
And you have also seen this
before, I am sure.
I can relate the charge to the
capacitance and the voltage as q
is equal to Cv.
And q is in coulombs,
this is in farads and this is
in volts.
So there is some charge q
stored on the capacitor and it
is in coulombs and q is equal to
Cv.
So I can differentiate this
with respect to time to get the
current, and that becomes
i=dq/dt.
So the current at any given
time is dq/dt.
And so I substitute for q in
terms of Cv here.
That is what I get.
So the current i=d(Cv)/dt.
A 6.002 assumption,
capacitance in general can be
time-varying.
I can get time-varying
capacitors.
In fact, there are some sensors
which are capacitive.
And, as I talk,
my sound waves can change the
pressure on the top plate of the
capacitor.
And move the top plate of the
capacitor, thereby changing the
capacitance by moving the plate.
Remember d here,
as the plate moves closer I get
a higher capacitance.
So we won't be dealing,
unless explicitly said so,
with time-varying capacitances.
So what we can do is 6.002
allows us to write Cdv/dt.
So my current source capacitor
is Cdv/dt.
I can also write down the
energy, capacitors store energy.
E=1/2Cv^2.
I am sure you have seen all
this before in physics and so
on.
That is the amount of energy
stored in the capacitor if it is
holding a charge q.
Let me do a little
demonstration for you.
They don't make glasses like
they used to.
Our friend Lorenzo has charged
up this capacitor.
It is a huge capacitor.
It is a 250 volt capacitor so
it is nasty.
He has charged it up and has
kept it there.
And to show you that it does
contain stored charges it has
been sitting there holding
charge.
Maybe the first row should go
backwards, just step back for a
second.
I think you guys would be safe
but I just don't want to take
any chances.
This is holding a bunch of
charge.
It is kind of sitting there.
If I short the terminals it
should try to say oh,
I've got a path,
let me get my charge out.
All right.
Let's do it.
This is always a scary moment
for me.
And I say a little prayer
before I do this.
Good?
OK.
Gee, you guys would love to see
me getting fried,
huh?
All right.
Let's see.
So it did contain charge.
So there is a reason why
Lorenzo puts one hand inside his
pocket when he shorts it,
because there is a natural
tendency to hold the wire with
both hands, and la,
la, la, la, la and put it
across the capacitor.
By doing this you are
guaranteed that you will just be
touching it with one hand.
Hopefully you folks will
remember for life that a
capacitor can sit around and
hold its charge for a while.
All right.
That is enough of fun and
games.
Let's get on with our business
of building circuits.
What I am going to do is,
as I promised you,
I am going to close the loop on
that example by halfway through
the next lecture.
I'm going take you on a bit of
a journey involving capacitors
and resistors and involving some
analysis, and then we will close
it all up for you at about the
middle of next lecture.
What I would like to do next is
here is a new element.
And let's do some fun stuff
with elements.
Well, you know about voltage
sources, you know about
resistors, let's put them
together and see how they
behave.
Let's have a capacitor here,
C, vc(t) and some current i.
What I am going to do,
in general, whenever I have
something new or something
strange, let's say like a
capacitor or some other device.
It is interesting to model the
rest of the circuit behind it if
it contains only resistors and
voltages and linear elements as
a Thevenin equivalent.
So let me do that.
This is R and this is vi.
This stuff in the back is my
standard pattern,
voltage source in series with a
resistor, and I connect that
across my capacitor.
But remember,
although you saw those funny
wave forms and so on,
the capacitor is a linear
device.
Because you can see from here
that the current relates to
dv/dt.
That is a linear operation.
You don't see V squareds and
Vis and things like that in
there.
It's is a linear device.
Let's go back to our trusty old
method, the node method.
If you just blindly apply the
node method and simply grunge
through a bunch of math,
you should be able to get to
the answer, that is for some
voltage v or some form of
voltage vi, I should be able to
figure out what vc looks like.
So let's do that.
This is the node that is of
interest here with the unknown
node voltage vc.
So let me apply the node
method.
(vc-vi)/R is the current going
this way.
That plus the current through
the capacitor should equal zero.
And what is the current through
the capacitor?
The node method tells me that,
get the current in terms of the
element values.
We know that the current is
given by CdvC/dt.=O.
Just shuffling things around a
little bit, I can write RC
dvc/dt+vc=vi.
We are writing the node
equation and then getting the
equation that characterizes this
little circuit.
Notice here that this has units
of volts.
And since I have time here,
this also must have units of
time.
Let's go about solving this
little circuit and understanding
how it behaves.
The specific example that we
will look at looks like this.
Let's say the capacitor voltage
at time T=0 is V0.
This is given.
So at time T=0,
I am telling you that the
capacitor contains a charge.
And because of that there is a
voltage V0 across it.
That capacitor had a voltage of
250 volts across it and most of
the devices we deal with in
laptops and so on today,
like the Pentium IV,
voltages are on the order of
1.5 volts, very small voltages.
So that is the value in the
capacitor, the voltage.
That is called a state.
This is called the state,
capacitor state.
It is the state of the
capacitor.
And I also give you that
vi(t)=VI.
So my voltage is VI.
And somehow,
I am not telling you how,
but some how it arranged to
have the capacitor voltage be V0
at time T=0.
Now I want to look to the
solution to this for t greater
than or equal to zero.
And in that time my voltage vi
is at some capital VI,
some DC voltage VI.
So I am going to solve the
differential equation RC
dvc/dt+vc=vi given these two
values.
Input is DC voltage VI and VC0
is V0, the initial charge in the
capacitor.
So from now until almost to the
end of the lecture,
it is just going to be math by
solving this very simple first
order differential equation.
And the key here will be that
throughout 6.002 we will be
following one method to solve
these.
There are many methods to
solving differential equations,
and we will follow one method.
That method is called the
method of homogenous and
particular solutions.
In 1802, I believe,
you would have learned maybe
this, and certainly other
methods.
You can use any method to solve
it.
We will just stick to one
method.
And this is also used in the
course notes.
In this method what we do is
take the solution VC by finding
two other components.
One is called the homogenous
solution.
And summing that up with the
particular solution.
And that is the total solution.
So total solution is the sum of
the homogenous and the
particular solutions.
And the method has three steps.
As I said before,
we will be using this method
again and again with every
differential equation that we
encounter in this course.
And you won't encounter a while
lot.
The first step we find the
particular solution.
The second step,
find the homogenous solution.
The total solution is the sum
of the two.
And then find ---
There will be some unknown
constants depending on the
equation that you have.
And in the end we simply find
the unknown constants by
applying the initial conditions
that we have.
Boom, boom, boom.
Particular.
Homogenous.
Find constants.
Three things.
So let's go about solving this
equation and apply those three
conditions.
Again, remember,
what I am doing now for the
next 10 minutes or 15 minutes is
using math that you know about
to simply solve this first order
of differential equations.
There is nothing really new
that I am going to talk about
here.
One is to find the particular
solution vCP,
which will then be added into
the vCH to get me the solution.
So the way you find the vCP is
you find any solution that
satisfies this equation.
This is the equation.
You find any solution that
satisfies it.
And find the simplest possible
solution that money can buy.
Find it.
That's the particular solution.
Any solution is fine.
In this case,
a really simple one would be
vCP equals VI.
Let's see if a constant works.
One thing you will realize in
differential equations is that
they are actually much simpler
than they seem.
And the reason is that almost
every time you have to assume
you know the answer,
and then you are checking to
see what you assumed was
correct.
Assume the answer is this like
you are really smart,
and then check it out and say
oh, yeah, that must have been
the answer.
So here we assume that I think
VI is going to work so let's try
it out.
Substituting in here.
RC dvc/dt is 0.
vi is a constant.
So I get vi equals vi,
so therefore this is a
particular solution.
Done.
I substitute vi here.
So dvi/dt=0.
This vanishes and vi=VI.
Bingo.
Therefore, VI is a solution to
this equation.
So I am done with my vCP.
And in general what you have to
do is use trial and error.
By trial and error try out a
bunch of solutions until you get
lucky.
In general, again,
in all of 6.002 for many of the
excitations a simple constant
usually suffices.
Our second step is to find the
homogenous solution.
And we can also do that very
quickly.
And to do that we have to find
a general solution to the
homogenous equation.
The homogenous equation is the
same differential equation but
with the drive set to zero.
We want to follow a set pattern
to solve the differential
equations here,
and the set pattern is find
vCP, vCH, find constants.
And to find vCH we are also
going to follow a set pattern to
find the homogenous solution.
So we set the drive to zero,
so vi is set to be zero.
And I need to find a general
solution to this.
As I promised earlier,
diff equations are really,
really simple because the way
we are going to solve them is we
are going to assume we know the
answer and then go check it.
So let's try Ae^st.
Let's try and see if this can
solve this particular equation
for some values of A and S.
I am telling you that the
solution is going to be of this
form.
Assume it.
And then simply go ahead and
find me A and S,
and do that by substituting it
back into the equation and find
out the corresponding As and Ss.
So let's go ahead and do that.
I get RC.
I substitute this back up so I
get dAe^(st)/dt+Ae^st=0.
And let me plug that in and see
what comes.
I get RCAse^st+Ae^st=0.
I want to discard the trivial
solution of A being 0.
That is a trivial solution so I
will discard that.
And what I will do is cancel
out the As from here,
assuming A is not zero,
and cancel e^st here.
And what is left is RCs+1=0.
What this is saying is that if
I can find an S such that this
is true then Aest is a general
solution to my homogenous
equation.
This is easy enough.
And so S=-1/RC.
If I choose my S to be -1/RC
then the simple math that I have
gone through shows me that this
must be the solution to the
homogenous equation.
Or in other words
vCH=Ae^(-t/RC).
All this is saying is that
Ae^(-t/RC) is a solution to my
homogenous equation.
A is an unknown constant.
A is some constant.
I don't know what that is yet.
Notice RC has popped up again.
And the cool thing about RC is
that, this is time,
this also has units of time.
We commonly represent RC as
some time constant tau,
as units of time.
Associated with that circuit is
the time constant tau,
which is simply RC.
I commonly write this as
Ae^(-t/tau).
I am very the end here.
I have the particular solution
here.
I have got the homogenous
solution there.
I need to tell you about
something else.
The way I found the homogenous
solution was in four steps.
I assumed a solution of the
form Ae^st.
I created this equation here in
S.
This is called the
characteristic equation for that
circuit.
We will see this time and time
again for RC and other forms of
circuits.
Assume a solution of this form.
Construct the characteristic
equation.
Find the roots of the
characteristic equation.
In this case it is an equation
in S.
So this is the root.
And then form the solution
based on that root.
Four steps.
Ae^st, characteristic equation,
root and then write down the
general homogenous solution.
Four steps there.
And finally I want to write
down the total solution.
And the total solution is
simply vCP+vCH.
And vCP was VI and vCH was
Ae^(-t/tau).
tau was simply RC.
That is my solution.
Now, remember the last step.
The last step was form the
total solution and find out the
remaining constants.
Find out the remaining
constants by using my initial
conditions.
At t=0, I know that vC=V0.
I know that.
And so therefore I can
substitute t=0 to find the
constant.
So I know that VO=VI+A.
t=0, this thing becomes 1,
and so I get this equation from
which I get A=V0-Vi.
In other words,
my solution vC is simply
VI+(VO-VI) e^(-t/tau).
So the last 15 minutes have
just been math.
No electrical engineering here,
but electrical engineering
stopped at the point where you
wrote this differential equation
down, went through a bunch of
math and came up with a
solution.
Purely mathematically.
So here I simply used math to
get you the solution.
And, as I have been promising
you throughout this course,
in the next lecture I will give
you an intuitive EE method of
doing it.
Real electrical engineers,
real EECS folks don't do it
this way.
Real EECS folks do it
intuitively.
And I will show you how to do
it in four easy seconds in the
next lecture.
But you need to understand the
foundations of how this comes
about, and so this is the
answer.
You can also get the current iC
is simply Cdvc/dt.
I won't do that for you,
but you can simply
differentiate it and get the
current.
So I can plot for you vC,
time t, vC.
The intuitive way of looking at
this is I have VI which is the
final value of the voltage.
When t is infinity this part
goes to zero so the vC is simply
VI.
And then there is a component
V0-VI which decays according to
this starting out at an initial
value of V0.
Notice when t is zero vC is V0,
you can see that in the
equation, and so it starts out
at V0 and ends up at VI.
I start here,
I end up here.
And this portion V0-VI decays
out over time like this.
And this decay is governed by
the RC time constant or tau.
I am going to show you very
quickly a couple of examples of
wave forms, one that goes like
this and one that looks like
this.
This is when I start with some
value V0 and I don't apply any
input, it should decay down to
zero, t, t, vC,
vC.
If I apply zero for VI then
this should simply decay down to
nothing over time.
And if I apply some VI but
there is no state in the
capacitor then that same
equation is going to look like
this.
You can go and confirm for
yourselves that when I apply
some input but the capacitor has
zero state, I start at zero,
I finish up at VI and my wave
form looks like this.
There you go.
That's the first one.
The second one where I have 5
volts on the capacitor and no
input.
Assume that at time equals zero
I take away an input,
short the input voltage to
ground for example,
apply zero volts.
You will see the decay from 5
volts to 0 volts.
And in the first case I start
with zero volts in my capacitor,
I apply input of 5 volts,
and notice that at t=0 the
capacitor rises up to that
level.
So notice that these circuits
with capacitor and resistors are
typified by wave forms that are
exponential rises and
exponential decays.
We will see more of that next
time.